Kyle Moretti, LA Film School Student: When
writing a story do you think it’s important
to write the story around a transmedia structure
or to extend it to transmedia after you have
already developed the story?
Houston Howard, Transmedia Author/Speaker:
So when you are developing stories I think
you have to understand that you have to execute
this single story by itself no matter what
other transmedia idea that you have.
I think the tendency can be I get so focused
on all the stories that I don’t execute
any individual story the right way and that’s
a mistake because you have to understand if
your movie isn’t good, if your script isn’t
good nothing works.
If your TV pilot good nothing works.
Now what I would say is I’m a fan of developing
the transmedia plan first and understanding
how all the stories interplay and understanding
your story world and understand where the
opportunities are and then once you have that
sort of structure and that architecture at
play and you understand what part of the puzzle
this individual story is, then what you do
is set that aside, you set all that aside
and then you’ve just got to dive in and
make sure you write an awesome script and
an awesome pilot and execute that thing.
But when you’re writing it you will naturally
be building in new opportunities because you’ll
understand how this interplays with the other
stories, you’ll understand more about your
story world and naturally you’re going to
start lacing things in that if you hadn’t
done that work first you wouldn’t have which
means then if you do all of the transmedia
opportunities after the fact one or two things
are going to happen is you’re probably going
to say “Oh I need to go rewrite my script
to be able to accommodate for all of these
things.
But then it may not feel natural or organic.
Or you are just going to say “I’m going
to leave it as it is,” and then it feels
disconnected and you are not going to get
the experience that you want.
It’s a balance.
If you don’t develop it as you’re writing,
I think you develop the broad plan from an
IP perspective this is my roadmap.
If I’m going to drive from LA to New York
and I’m going to look at the map and I see
my route that I’m going to take (this is
the broad route that I’m going to take)
and I map that and I understand where I am
going, I understand how to get there but eventually
I need to get in the car and I’m not going
to be starting at the map the entire time
I’m in the car and I’ll make minor adjustments
as I’m in the car.
I’ll get off at certain rest stops.
I’ll maybe take a different road here but
I still already understand the direction that
I’m going.
The problem is I think most people jump in
the car and they don’t even have a destination.
They just say “I’m just going to drive.”
That just ends up being more work on the back
end.
Personally I hate to rewrite, I hate rewriting.
I think all writers hate rewriting and so
I want to minimize my rewriting process as
much as possible which means then I think
you just build an IP design, set that aside
and then go.
And I think that the balance of that is sometimes
tricky and you kind of learn your way but
I think that’s the best way forward.